I was kind of like just in this gray
area of like who am I like is there like
do I have a purpose like is there
anything like that I can do besides this
Willow Smith shocked her famous mom Jada
Pinkett Smith during their latest
episode of their Facebook watch series
read table talk while discussing Lots
the 17 year old reveals that she lost
her sanity shortly after her hit song
wit my hair came out in 2010 when she
was just 10 years old
after all of that kind of settled down
and it was like a kind of low like I was
just listening to a lot of dark music
and like it was just so crazy and I was
just like plunged into this like black
hole mm-hm and I was like cutting myself
Jada and willows grandmother Adrienne
Banfield Jones were shocked by the teens
revelation what yeah and doing crazy
things really what would you cut
yourself and [ __ ] like a long time ago
cutting yourself where on my wrist I
mean you can't even see it but like
there's still a little something there
but like totally lost my sanity for a
moment there
willow added that she didn't tell her
family including dad Will Smith but she
did confide in a friend and eventually
stopped that's good to freak out it's
like been like five years willow I had
no idea yeah I never saw it
I never saw any signs of that it's crazy
yeah it's crazy
[Music]
you